What's going on? Alan Dragu here, L Copy
Go. And in today's video, we are going
to be tier ranking 21 copywriting books
that I have personally read and studied
over the last 5 years in my
copyrightiting journey. And we're going
to break down which are the best ones
all the way to which are the worst ones,
ones that you should avoid. And just a
heads up, I'm going to link every single
book in the description below. And
remember, this is my opinion. So if you
don't resonate with my opinion, I don't
care. It's fine. Like whatever. And if
there's a book that I don't mention in
today's video, drop it down in the
comments below. Let me know. I may or
may have not read it. So, I'm happy to
give you my opinion on it. But let's
dive into the video. Actually, before we
dive into the video, I do have a gift
that if this gift were on this 21 tier
list, my 63 copyrighting cash cow tips.
That's right. I'm talking about
copyrightiting catalyst. It would be S
tier. Complete S tier, baby. This is one
of the cream of the crop things that I
put thousands of hours of study and
dissection to put together for you
absolutely free. So, if you hit the link
in the description below, it's gratis,
okay? It doesn't cost you a dollar, but
it will make you mucho. So, go ahead,
put your email in below, I'll gift it to
you for free. Okay, let's wrap that up.
Back into the video. Okay, diving in.
Let's take a look at this list. All
right, we got 21 bangers. Or are they
bangers? Okay, we we don't know yet. All
right, let's dive in. Let's dive in with
the first book. I think this is a David
Garfinkle book and it is advertising
headlines that will make you rich. I'm
going to put this one on B tier. Okay,
solid B. And by the way, B isn't bad. B
is bueno. Okay, that's what B stands
for, right? So, Bueno, I think this is a
really good book, especially for
beginners. All right. And the reason
that I really like this book is because
it breaks down headlines and formulas
into really digestible, I hate to say
templates, but basically like templates,
like how they work, why they work, and
it's just a really good breakdown of
headlines, which ding ding. If you've
been in copywriting for more than 2
seconds, you know that headlines are by
far one of the most important things
that you could possibly have uh a skill
set for in writing copy. If you don't
get this right, you ain't going to get
much else right. All right. So, this is
a really good book for beginners. The
reason I wouldn't put it in an A or an S
tier. The headlines that he breaks down
and the templates and the formulas that
he uses are pretty canned, i.e. like
they I wouldn't use them as my first
go-to headlines cuz they're not unique
and they've been used so many times
that, you know, you could kind of tell
it's a template, it's a formula,
everybody else has used it a million
times. And so, it it's just not my go-to
if I if I'm coming up with something
unique, a different angle. But if I'm in
a crunch, I'm in a rush, and I need
something that I know will work, that's
a great book to start with. So, Solid
Bueno. Okay, Solid Bueno. The next book
is Great Leads. Okay, great leads
already so fast. I'm actually going to
put that in the S tier. Um, and that S
tier is just top cream of the crop. Uh,
just the sirloin steak, right? That's
what a sirloin steak of it, right? The
reason I'm throwing great leads into
that top tier echelon is because one of
the other books on this list,
Breakthrough Advertising by Eugene
Schwarz, breaks down the market
awareness, market sophistication, right?
Funnels, formulas, frameworks, whatever
you want to call it. Well, I think Great
Leads actually takes that market
awareness and market sophistication and
makes it even more accessible, simple,
digestible. uh just the way that uh the
two guys that wrote it explain it and
walk you through. It's basically uh like
how to write headlines and intro
paragraphs, which are the most important
parts of writing any kind of copy uh on
steroids. I wish I would have read this
book way earlier on in my copywriting
journey. I cannot recommend this enough.
And and candidly, it does such a good
job breaking down the uh breakthrough
advertising methods uh for like 15
bucks, right? Like you can get this on
Kindle for like 15 bucks and
breakthrough advertising is 125 bucks.
So a total S tier for me, a must-read
for every single copywriter. All right,
the next book is copyrightiting. I don't
know who wrote this book. Uh I don't
remember the name of the author, but to
me,
this is a
our first D. No. Yeah, this one is a
dud. Okay, this one is a dud. The reason
I don't I I don't really like this book.
I wouldn't recommend it to anybody is
because as the subtitle, what does the
subtitle say? Successful
writing for design, advertising, and
marketing, right? So, what they're
telling you is we don't have a string of
direct response copy in our bones. Okay?
This is more of like sexy, cool, clever
copy that we want to put on billboards
and magazines and it ain't good. Yeah.
It's basically just a really
welldesigned book with a bunch of
pictures, images, and taglines. It's
more like tagline writing more than
copywriting. They're trying to get you
with these sexy cool taglines. And it's
not copy. At least it's not pure true
direct response copy. And that's the
only real copy. Okay, let's be honest.
All right, that's the only real copy.
So, that's a total Dtier for me. Uh, I
barely made it through that whole book.
I was kind of hoping that I would uh be
pleasantly surprised, but I was not. So,
I would continue to avoid that one. All
right, the next one. Quickstar
Copywriting by Clayton Makepiece. That
goes straight into the S tier. claim
makepiece does the works with this. And
candidly, this is not a book, but you
it's in book format, so I want to keep
it in here. It is a $1,500 course that
you have to buy through like Gary
Halpert's site. Again, I'll link the
description below, but it's worth every
penny of $1,500. It's like 2,000 pages
in a binder and it has sales letters and
it breaks down everything. It is
literally the A to Z bible of everything
you need to know about true direct
response copyrightiting. In fact, if
there was one thing that I would keep on
this list and I wiped the other 20
things, it's Quick Start Copyrightiting
by Clayton Makepiece. Uh I I truly have
not experienced any courses or books
more uh depthy and self-explanatory and
just so helpful. Well, it's not
self-explanatory, but you get what I'm
saying. It's just so helpful in in all
aspects. I continue to go back to it for
offer creation, headlines, body copy,
structure. It's a true direct response.
Uh 11 out of 10 for me. Cannot recommend
it enough. Complete S tier. Next is the
Robert Collier letter book. Some of you
guys are going to shoot me for this one.
That is the C tier. I'm putting that in
the kaka tier. Okay. No, no, no. It's
it's not absolute trash. Here's the good
thing that the the Rama call your letter
book does. All right. It is true direct
response. Okay. It is true direct
response. It has great concepts in it,
but candidly it is so outdated. I think
the book is like 110 years old is 1910
or 1920 whenever it was in I think 1920.
It is it is so visibly outdated that
even as they're like in the offers like
I don't even understand the offers half
the time cuz I'm like is this a good
offer? Is this a bad offer? Uh the way
they wrote the letters it's it's just
and it's so try and dense and you really
got to go through a lot of pages. Now
maybe I'm just too dumb. Maybe it went
way over my head and I was like, you
know, like it just did not resonate with
me. So, that could be on me. Some of you
guys, some some of the legends are like,
"What?" They want to jump through the
screen and punch me in the face. But,
you know what? It's my channel. Build
your own freaking YouTube channel. Do
your own S tier list and put it on the S
tier if you want, but this ain't your
channel. Okay. But yeah, it's just not
not great. I wouldn't recommend it.
Wouldn't read it again. Barely made it
through the first time. No go for me.
The next one I'm going to put Oo, copy.
Finally, a Ben Settle book. All right, I
I got through five or six of these
before getting to Ben.
You guys think I'm going to put
everything S tier for Ben, but I'm not.
Even though I love Ben, this one is an
absolute A tier, though. Okay, Copy
Slacker. Complete A tier. Now, again,
granted, this is a book. Okay, it's
right behind me. It is a book. It's like
1,000 pages, but it's also like a,000
bucks. It's literally like 900 or $1,000
from Ben Settle. So, not an accessible
book. However, again, however, it is so
chalk full of sales letter and
copywriting wisdom that I cannot
recommend it enough. In fact, not only
does Ben break down how he was pumping
out sales letters in like a week or two
weeks, you know, without AI and they
were good and sold and they it's just
incredible, but he does commentary
across like 50 of his best sales letter
sales letters in the back. So he'll
literally like under the line he'll
explain how he got there and how he
wrote it. You could it's basically like
a,000 bucks gets you hours and hours and
hours of consulting with Ben Settle and
how his mind works in these amazing
sales letters. How how is that not
infinitely more valuable than the money
you paid for it? Right? So complete A
tier for me. Uh the reason it's not S
tier is because it is more sales letter
which I feel like is uh the dark arts of
the copywriting world. Not not many
brands are doing like traditional direct
mail sales letters. I wish I could get
to do more of them. And so it's just so
niche uh of a topic that I it's not
broadly applicable to all copywriting. I
mean you can apply but again it's so
niche in just the sales letter world uh
that that if it was just copy in general
uh it would totally S tier for me. Now,
I know some of you guys are already
punching through the screen on that, but
again, my opinions were not. All right,
let's keep going. The next one is
the boron letters. Where am I
copyrightiting fo you guys? Is it S
tier? Am I one of those guys? Is it D
tier? Am I one of those guys? It is D
tier. Oh man, some of you guys, you're
like, "No, copycat. I lost all my
respect for you." Listen. All right. It
is a D tier for me. Now, I want to
preface this with I love Gary Halper. In
fact, I paid a guy on Upwork like 200
bucks to collect all the Gary Halper
letters for me and put them in
chronological order into this
like,000page document that I've printed
into two massive binders in my house.
And so, I'm a big Gary Halper fan. I
love his sales letters. I love his
writing styles. I'm just not a Boron
letters fan. More like the bull ring
letters. Okay, you guys have heard that
time and time again where he riffs on
and on to his son. It It's good. Some of
it's about eating fruit and doing some
road work and like you know you get Ada
like I'll teach you ADA. He teaches you
some some cool market research stuff
with SRDS and just some mindset stuff.
But like it felt like it could have been
a blog post to be honest. It could have
been a two-page blog post and it would
have been just as valuable. But and
maybe it was a time I read Boron
letters. By the time I got to Boron
Letters, I was like, "That's it. I I
definitely knew all this." And even the
way you explained it, uh, you know, I've
heard it said better. So, not not a big
fan. Not a big fan. Wouldn't be my first
go-to. I It's a classic read. You could
totally read it, but not not my thing.
All right. Cracker Jack Selling Secrets
by Ben Settle. I'm going to put this in
the A tier. Okay. Uh, again, Ben Ben is
an A for me. One, the writing style is
awesome. Super fun, really lighthearted.
I uh I love the chapters. Okay, so the
chapters are really short. He's got like
a hundred selling secrets in here that
could be copywriting, business,
marketing, whatever it is. Uh but
overall, I I would apply it to copy. And
the chapters are just so digestible. The
book is so short. There's so much uh
pound-for-pound wisdom in the book that
I almost feel like I could read it eight
times and still be like, "Oh, man,
that's excellent. Oh, that's fantastic."
You can read it in an afternoon and just
be covered with Ben Settle gems. An
enjoyable read. Great storytelling. Uh
lot of fun. Total A tier. Um it's it's
it's not S tier for me just just cuz it
it it doesn't hit that echelon of of
excellence. But but well I mean it is
excellent. But you know what I'm saying?
Like there's just a tier that sirloin
tier. You know what I'm talking about.
Uh but total A tier. Highly recommend
it. All right. Copywriting secrets.
Kickass copywriting. Uh
John Carlton absolute S tier. This is
one of the first copywriting books I
read and it's not expensive. It's like
50 bucks. Uh it's it's a it's a course
and honestly it just opened up my entire
world of copyrightiting which is so
funny because I remember he mentioned in
a podcast he like pumped it out in like
two weeks. He just needed something to
sell. He's like I just need something to
sell. And he like wrote it, launched it
and it's been one of the most incredible
courses I've ever read. uh just his
philosophy, his approach, his
storytelling. Uh he's got a chapter in
the end where he where he just gives
some life philosophy and I just it just
warms my heart too and just the
copywriting concepts. It's it's what I
thought the Boron letters would be, but
it wasn't. And John Carlton absolutely
smashed it out of the park. So total S
tier. Everybody must read, especially if
you're writing sales letters. If you're
writing sales letters, he is the goat um
through this kick-ass copywriting. So So
highly recommend it. very good copy by
my friend Edis Schlainer. That is an A.
That is a total A in my book. What I
really loved about this book is is it's
as if like Seth Goden and Austin Cleon
had a baby and it was Eddie Schlainer
and then Eddie Schlainer went into the
copywriting world and wrote this book.
The chapters are short. The storytelling
is amazing. There's like 230 concepts,
right? copyrightiting concepts uh that
that are just gems of the gem, right?
Total A tier. It's an absolutely fun
read. Uh the only caveat to this is that
would have made it S tier is uh to me it
doesn't build on top of each other,
right? Like the concepts are more uh
randomized, right? Where it's it's not
like fundamentals A to Z. It is more
random, but it's a lot of concepts all
at once. So, you'll pick up a lot of
stuff, but then you really got to piece
meal it together yourself.
um and what that looks like. Uh which is
totally fine. It's a great book, but but
overall if it had built on top of
itself, I think it would have been a
total S tier, but overall uh one of the
best modern-day copyrightiting books I
have ever read. Highly recommend. All
right, scientific advertising. Claude
Hopkins, The Godfather. Do not
disrespect Claudy, man. Come on over
here. In fact, did you know that Claude
the AI was named after Claude Hopkins?
That's a lie. I don't even know why I
said that. That's a complete lie. All
right, I'm going to put this in the B
category. Oh, yeah, you guys are going
to shoot me. Listen, I love uh
scientific advertising. Uh I don't think
it's outdated where I suppose there's
like a book on here earlier. Yeah, the
Robert Collier book uh which is slightly
older than the Claude Hopkins book, but
the Claude Hopkins book is like 1930s,
but it doesn't feel like it's in the
1930s. He actually does such a good job
uh maintaining uh the overall concept
and timeliness uh of the book itself.
It's just super well written. Concept is
clean. Even David Oggovie was like,
"Everybody must read Scientific
Advertising seven times before they
decide to run an ad for me. Gary
Benzangga swears by it." Here's here's
the reason why I put it in the B tier is
because I actually philosophically
disagree with Claude Hopkins on his
approach to direct response
copyrightiting. He is hardcore against
entertainment in advertising. He is like
everything is sales sales like we're not
selling, we're persuading like all this
stuff. But in today's modern world, I
really feel like you can uh you know
intertwine uh entertainment into
selling. I do it on my email list every
single day and it works like bananas. So
candidly, we just have a totally
different approach on that. But I do
like taking the scientific advertising
principles and using data to measure
what works and what doesn't work. All
right, the next book we got another
David Garfinkle in here and we are going
to do breakthrough copywriting. That to
me I'm going to put that that's another
B. That's another bueno. It's a good
book, right? Not a tier, not S tier, but
it is Btier. What I like about
Breakthrough Copywriting is it's really
short. It's like a 100 pages or less. Uh
very fundamental, very entry level.
solid 12 bucks on Amazon. Uh, good
basics. He even has a lot of the
headline like advertising headlines that
will make you rich. He has a lot of
those formulas in Breakthrough
Copywriting. The concepts are really
simple. Uh, I think it's a great
entry-level book. Nothing in that book
like really really blows my mind by any
means, right? It's very it's very entry
level, which is fine cuz, you know,
everybody does have to get back to the
fundamentals, back to the basics, and it
is a good refresher. It's an easy read.
It's very quick, but but at the same
time, I'm I'm always looking for uh
different angles, different
storytelling, uh different ways of
thinking about copyrightiting that I
hadn't thought about before. And I think
I just read this book too late where I
was expecting a little bit more. I was I
was pretty far along in my
copyrightiting journey. All right, next
book. Ben Settle. This is Bizworld.
Okay, Bisworld. Let me see. Where am I
going to put this one? I'm going to give
this one a C. Oh, don't shoot me. Don't
shoot me. I know. Listen, I love Ben. I
love the concept of world building. In
fact, what this book did for me, if
anything, is it got me excited about his
real course that's going to be coming
out on world building. So, this is Ben's
Biz World like lead magnet type Amazon
book. It's like 15 bucks um on on
Amazon, and it introduces the concept of
world building inside of copyrightiting,
which I think is absolutely genius. The
concept is pure genius. I've I've taken
so much and actually applied it to my
business. But candidly, by the time I
read this book, I had pretty much
digested all of the same concepts he's
talked about, but in his daily emails,
cuz I like religiously read his daily
emails. And a lot of the book is
transcript where it's like a
conversation between him and his friends
and and there's a lot of gems in there,
but there's just a lot of uh riff raff.
You know, Ben, he like he likes to riff
a lot, you know, and he's doing that.
And it just took a lot of that
commentary to dig through. A lot of it
was very repetitive, which he warns you.
He warns you that a lot of it is
repetitive. Uh it just wasn't like my
best cup of of Ben subtlety. Uh
especially when I enjoy his email player
so much. I enjoy all his books. I've
spent thousands of dollars with Ben. Um
and you know, my expectations are just
so high with that one. So So not a not a
like killer read for me. probably
wouldn't reread again, but I would
definitely buy his worldbuing course
when it comes out cuz I know every
course he's ever put out, long form book
has been just like top tier. So,
absolutely highly recommend that stuff.
All right, the persuasion story code.
Fantastic. This one is like an
underrated book. A lot of people don't
know about this one. I'm going to put
this one in the A category. Okay, this
one really good. really really good
because it is I maybe the only
copywriting book that talks about
storytelling and persuasion in the same
book. Right? There are other
storytelling books and there's other
persuasion books but very few that
actually teach storytelling with
copyrighting. I think the only other
thing I've I've seen about it is like
Daniel Thrasell has email storyteller uh
which talks about email storytelling. Uh
but I haven't seen anything outside of
just like guru storytelling courses that
are no good. Absolutely trash. Wouldn't
recommend. And maybe storyw worthy, but
storyworthy isn't a copywriting book.
So, Persuasive Story Code, highly
underrated, flies under the radar. Uh
highly recommend. A tier book. Everybody
should read it, especially if you're
writing email copywriting. uh because
this has really injected a lot of the
entertainment and angles and ideas that
I use for for great storytelling and
angles in my daily email. So, highly
recommend copywriting crib sheets Ben
Settle. Another Ben Settle. Obviously,
I'm a big Ben Settle fan. This to me is
a solid B tier book. Okay, really solid
book. I would actually say good. Uh
right, maybe almost a tier. Uh but it is
sheets, right? It is fundamentals.
He's saying that in the thing. Uh and
and so that's that's not a knock against
the book. It's a short read, short
chapters, highly entertaining, lot of
good stuff. Uh it is kind of sporadic
all over the place. It's just like copy
it's like a brain dump of copywriting
tips and tricks and ideas. So it's not
really like a toz cohesive by any means
where it builds on top of each other
where again that I'm big on that. I'm
really big on like something building on
top of each other. You unveil one uh one
thing that unveils the next thing and it
continues to unlock for me. This one's
just like a free-for-all tips and a lot
of them are so good. In fact, I I
continue um to use concepts from this
book all the time. So, very solid read,
very fun. If you are a big settle a big
Ben Settle fan, you will enjoy uh this
one for sure. Highly recommend reading
Oglev on Advertising. That is straight
to the Bueno category. Guys, don't shoot
me. Okay. Oglev on Advertising. I love
this book for one core reason is his big
idea approach.
the there's an entire like chapter or
two based on like how he came up with
big ideas which is like Obie's saying
right like he came up with the idea of
big ideas which is incredible in it
sense and later I do think there is an
Agora book uh the big black Agora book
that I think took the David Oglevie
formula and made it better in my opinion
uh but overall this book introduced me
to the big idea concept which was
amazing uh the reason it's not A or S
tier is because there is a lot of just
like overarching uh concepts that you
know candidly I don't I don't care for
don't apply uh necessarily to the world
of copyrighting today. He talks a lot
about like television ads. He talks
about like running an agency which I
think is cool if you're a David Oggov
fan and you're just getting uh some and
you're just getting some background
which by the way the King of Madison
Avenue is a great book if you are a
David Oggov fan. I read those at the
same time. on King of Madison Avenue and
Ogle Von advertising and it's just great
for like getting the background on his
life and stuff. Uh but like just great
copywriting bangers. This one is a good
one to have. Definitely a good one to
read. It wouldn't be top of my list. U
but but highly recommend. The Ultimate
Sales Letter by Dan Kennedy. Absolute A
tier. The fact that this book is $15 is
is insane. And you know, it's so funny
because the the first time I got hired
to do a sales letter, I had no idea how
to do a sales letter. So, I ordered this
Dan Kennedy uh the ultimate sales letter
book and it got me through those like
first two or three sales letters where I
just I I understood the concepts. I
thought they were absolutely uh
incredible. Dan Kennedy is one of the
most prolific sales letter copywriters
in the world. I love his idea of
understanding the target market. And in
fact, this book really opened up the
whole target audience and really
mastering the audience as opposed to the
writing. I I up to that point, I was so
focused on the writing and the concepts
and the fundamentals of copywriting that
I didn't take knowing the market so
seriously until I read this book. It
really unlocked it for me. So, so I
think that's a personal moment why I'm
rating it so high, but also it's it's
Dan Kennedy. It's like come on, you you
know it's good, right? So So it's
definitely up there for me. Love it.
Love it. Love it. Highly recommend.
Definitely grab that one. The AdWeek
Copy Writing Handbook. This one is Come
on. You thought I was Heck no. This one
is S tier all day long. Okay, think
about how when I said, you know, if I
had to wipe every single book off this
list and I could just leave quick start
copywriting. Okay, the Joe Sugarman
AdWee copywriting handbook is like that
for me, but the $15 version instead of
the $1,500 version, right? You could go
on Amazon, get the AdWe copywriting
handbook for 15 bucks, and you would get
everything you need to know copywriting
A to Z. You would understand all the
fundamentals. You would understand
leads, headlines, hooks, emotions,
authority, persuasion, right? Structure.
You would understand everything you need
to know in this one book. It's
absolutely incredible. Don't get me
wrong, it's not the most advanced and
in-depth tactics that that typically I'm
I'm like juicing for. Uh but overall,
that book is fundamentally one of the
greatest copywriting books ever written.
I cannot argue anybody who recommends
it. I've bought that book for so many
fresh copywriters uh that have been
local here and just know what I do and
things like that. I cannot recommend
that book enough. cannot recommend that
book enough. Highly, highly, highly say
put it in your cart right now. I wish I
was getting paid to sell you this book,
but I'm not getting paid. I just really
think if you've not read that book, you
are doing yourself a disservice. 10 out
of 10, 11 out of 10, 12 out of 10,
especially for 15 bucks. Makes no sense.
You're literally robbing him blind. A
tier. No, not a tier. S tier. Cash
advertising straight to the S tier. Cash
advertising straight to the S tier. In
fact, if I were to recommend two books
for you and only two books, AdWe
copyrightiting handbook, cash
advertising, you can get both of them
for less than 30 bucks. Uh, you read ADW
copyrightiting handbook to get the
fundamentals and then you read cash
advertising to really juice up the the
skills, right? Cash advertising, I feel
like he's got a lot of tricks up his
sleeve. It's like 101 tricks just way up
his sleeve. Absolutely demolishing it.
Does such an amazing job of being really
tactical, really practical. I cannot
tell you how many times I flipped
through that book and was just like, "Oh
yeah, I forgot about that." It you It is
literally like a glossery of advertising
tricks, copyrightiting tricks. Uh I
cannot recommend it enough. In fact, I
can't tell you how many times I have
bought a course and there are these
slimy gurus who have literally just like
copied and pasted cashizing into their
course. They're like 10 best whatever
and it's just cashizing, right? Like I'm
not going to name names, but if you're
on my email list, you know. Uh, but
people do this all the time. They
literally just take cash advertising,
put it in their course, and I'm like,
and it's so good. We're like, it is
good, but you didn't come up with it, so
why are you selling it? Okay, mucho. All
right, we're wrapping it up. We got the
Copywriters Handbook. Bob Blie. My guy
Bob Blie. I'm sliding him into the A
tier category. Awesome. Awesome. Okay,
here's what I really love about this
book is this is by far the most
versatile copywriting book on this list.
So, he goes through anything that needs
copy. He goes through presentations,
websites, meta ads, Google ads, emails,
uh, print, direct advertising, mail,
billboards, like he goes through it all.
Anything that has words written on it,
he's like, "Here's how to write copy for
that. Here's how to write copy for this.
Oh, you didn't know you could write copy
for this? I'm going to write copy for
that. And that's what he's I mean, he is
literally just if you can write if you
can think about copy, he got it. Okay,
he got he tell you how to do it. All
right, that book is genius. Now the one
thing again that I disagree with and I
mentioned this in scientific advertising
is Bob Bllye is a purist of copywriting
like sales being sales and he doesn't
like interjecting the entertainment with
it which I philosophically disagree with
because again I've done it many times in
emails meta ads landing pages where I
inject a lot of entertainment and it
sells like bananas but again Bob Bllye
has also sold a lot more stuff than I
have so kudos to him who am I to say
that his stuff doesn't work which it
does Right? We just fundamentally
disagree on that approach. So either
way, absolute a uh really highly
recommend. Love it. Love it. Love it.
And the last one, the legendary Eugene
Schwarz breakthrough advertising. I am
going to toss this in
S tier. Okay, S tier. You know, the only
reason Great Leads is in this S tier is
because this book exists. Okay,
Breakthrough Advertising is, I'm not
going to lie, it is a dense, thick read.
Okay, it is it is a slog to get through.
And the reason it is a slog to get
through is because like every sentence
is so freaking potent with marketing and
advertising wisdom that I'm ju I just
find myself like highlighting and
chewing and thinking like I'm just like,
"Oh man, how did Wow, I've never thought
of that before." It is just so chalk
full of incredible wisdom
um that I don't know I don't know how
else to explain it. It is definitely a
slow read. Uh it is definitely a thick
read and it is not for everybody. Okay,
it is not for everybody. But he goes
through market awareness um market
sophistication. He goes through those.
He goes through headlines. He goes
through audience desires and target
marketing. like he goes through what I
would consider is the fundamentals but
at a very advanced level. Okay, which is
very hard to do. It's hard to take the
basics and and talk about them at such
an advanced level. So, the fact that
he's able to merge that is absolutely
incredible. I cannot recommend it
enough. The only place that you could
really get it is through Titans
Marketing. My friend Brian Kurts, Chris
Mason, those guys, they have the rights
to it. I bought it from them. And when I
bought it, I also bought Breakthrough
Mastery, which Brian and Chris wrote
together to help you digest this book
even more because it's so dense and
there's so much to learn. It is like the
copywriting bible, okay? It is like you
really have to read this. If you don't
read this, I don't know what to tell
you. Okay, Ben Settle even talks about
he's read through it 101 15 times. He's
got notes and ideas and all just the
concepts are are absolutely insane. to
not put this on S tier would be an
absolute disservice. So, overall
wrapping up this video, lot of great
stuff out there. Lot of S's, okay, the
sirloins. Yes, baby. You got the A's, a
lot of awesomes. Got some buenos in
there, okay? You got some C's, you got a
couple D's. It is what it is, okay? You
got some kakas and some duds. Okay, it
is what it is. It's not a big deal.
Either way, I hope this video was
helpful for you. And if it was, please
do me a favor. Like the video, leave a
comment down below about a book that
maybe I left off or an opinion you
disagree with. I hope you disagree. You
know, I hope you get fired up in the
comments because all it does is just
juice up my algo and tell YouTube that
this video is awesome and it shows it to
more people. So yeah, get mad. Leave it
in the comments. That would be awesome.
I would love it if you got mad in the
comments. Or leave me happy comments.
That'd be great, too. Just leave me
comments, likes, subscribe to the
channel if you want more videos like
this. I appreciate it. I hope you enjoy.
Again, all the links in the description
below. Grab whatever you want. Enjoy it.
I do get a kickback on some of the
Amazon links. Uh other ones you're just
supporting friends of mine, so I
appreciate it. Chat with you next time.
El Copo out. What book is not on this
list? What did I miss? What's on my
shelf? What is on my shelf? Where's my
Oh, you know that one book that like um
copywriting expert secrets by I think
it's Jim Edwards or something. It's like
the first copyrightiting book I got. And
and I I like went through like 30 pages
and I was like, I don't get it.